gazprom is as much as
necessary and as much as possible we know
that now the technical capabilities for
pumping
steel have become less become less they
sued why because the process of
maintenance of various
units is extremely difficult in three days
due to the
restrictions of the melancholy that Europe introduced,
namely the European Union,
these  Sanctions do not make it possible to
promptly perform critical
maintenance to change spare parts
to carry out major repairs and other
routine maintenance with
equipment necessary for
practice as these works are carried out
by Gazprom, respectively, it will
be able to pump more,
Gazprom has been and remains a reliable guarantor of
all its obligations to fulfill
obligations, but  he cannot
guarantee pumping if the
imported imported unit
cannot be serviced due to European ones,
it is our spit in the fao spit, are we
envious
uxp coal and waving warrior
i.e.  aos father site asv subscribes
now on account to dance in this
write-up decide these plans for umm lie down
let wine raspberry for a face and
alphago hansa cilantro reach the site nobody
moselle beats al this matte especially
gishpanku
design agouti go fight
for
firms and
sound  when tit and relevant the form of anton
von kluge commanded a
flaw, then
another kansk assassin to reach over you land
in english and snowballs a new film
spar tie from sofin finn forest
months or years
I will get it we sat on a gishpanka root
pink satin